ever did it edited it I think it's the
Beatles sorry hey everybody welcome to
stream Coco look at this thing look at
what we won this is great yes and look
we're humble cuz I'm wearing my snow and
care shirt uh thank you to the Academy
thank you to all of you this is for you
guys for watching our Konan Without
Borders specials which are great and it
was a crazy weekend we just got back
from shooting our Japan episode which
was amazing
and we saw a lot of you in the chat when
Kona did karaoke when Conan was walking
around as a hard as you coud girl when
when I can't remember all the things we
did when Conan and Jordan had a
traditional meal and it's awesome so we
got this
it was amazing night lots to talk about
it was super fun this thing is heavy and
sharp
let's shirt feels sharp it is look at
those look at that's it that's a weapon
that's a weapon right there that's a
great weapon so yes this was amazing and
we'll be talking more about this as the
stream goes on but of course you can
watch all of our Kona Without Borders
episodes I think this was actually for
the three we've done this year which is
I think Israel Haiti and Italy which is
fantastic so all different and all fun
and all difficult in their own way and
it was great this was really fun
so and it was really it was great to see
our pals from Seth Meyers and SNL there
as well of course Congrats to John
Oliver Congrats to John Legend who got
the II got as well as Andrew Lloyd
Webber very funny
that's right yeah I saw John Legend in
the bathroom before they I mean wish him
a good luck as he did me and then we saw
him and Chrissy coming out of the party
as we were going in and we clicked
Demi's they say congratulations he's
like gratulations it was amazing we're
all friends also RuPaul congratulated us
here queer I got oh my god I kind of
think honestly our team was more excited
guys than to win an Emmy it was
absolutely unbelievable
emic Barsky awkward aardvark Dean cosmic
Dean cosmic we all won and amazing we
all want an amazing me together and also
speaking today we're gonna be playing
spider-man and not only rethinking
Academy and all of you for our amazing
Emmy win this year we are also thanking
the fine folks at Playstation check this
thing out guys look at this we come back
from Japan to this giant box bit of a
spoiler alert what it is on top but we
open this thing up look at this thing
look at this look at this first of all
they got I don't know if you can see
it's a giant look at this is crazy it's
a it's a ps4
spider-man ps4 you got the controller
over there and look at this you got all
these uh all these amazing I don't want
to pull it out here but it's also a
bunch of comic books there and as well
as I don't know what this is the
soundtrack to spider-man or something oh
these are the games we already took
those out because we're gonna be playing
so thank you to our great friends at
PlayStation for this insanely beautiful
and incredibly heavy by the way box
that's great
good lord oh yeah yeah all right so
anyway
cold-blood they send it to us
playstation senators it's this heavy
just hold this for a second it's crazy
but it's just like it's incredibly yeah
exactly exactly what's in the box what's
in the box I'll tell you what it is it's
a Spider Man console it's amazing so
today we're gonna be playing spider-man
if you haven't gotten this game we play
it a little bit we played a little bit
already offline and it's super fun
really really fun and we're kind of
talking I think we'll just start from
the beginning because it's great and not
everybody has this game so yeah we'll
start right away
that's right I think we should just keep
this Emmy on the couch right here next
to us yeah here but so maybe between us
here that's right burn the box blue moon
wolf why would we burn the box what are
you stupid but I gotta burn the box it's
awesome or I'm putting subtitles on
because then we don't have to listen
everybody hey Slayer darth what's up
does any ps4 owner not have this game I
don't know mole Matt or is it mole a
matte box a lot of dome and not
everybody has it
I've run with its is that that's right
ps4 clueless gamers this wouldn't get
fun one to do clueless gamer with so
cool games history by nature just
finished the taskmaster missions ooh
taskmaster he's one of you know I gotta
say one thing that's great about
spider-man he has an amazing rogues
gallery
you got like vulture Doc Ock Mysterio
Rhino all these great guys but then you
have other villains too that are also
amazing that are also kind of like bleed
over you got like kingpin you got a guy
a couple bleeped like the daredevil
spider-man ones are kind of the same he
went up against Punisher I know he's an
antihero but still you're gonna grade my
web swinging do it Jamaican run huh
I love this friggin game can't get
enough so I'm watching this at work cuz
I can't play Johnathan Fowler that's how
I feel I'm just getting over my dead
cells addiction I played dead cells of
the 11 hour plane ride to Japan I played
it probably nine hours on there there's
no big wheel well we can't have
everything can't we uh Jade de la venta
this looks incredible I agree
also I gotta say like I really love the
Batman games are really fun and the
combats great you get to soar around the
city but they're all at night that's a
little depressing you know my thing was
vibrating as the phone vibrated so
that's a little that's a little
depressing so it this is like beautiful
and and bright and fun as spider-man
should be by the way the spider-man have
any ice part villains I think he does
she has the guy in like the blue hoodie
with the fur around him and like the
weird 3d glasses
it's not mr. Frese it's yes he does
though
sub-zero maybe is that a person I love
driving through the city yes I agree I
agree
atsui in fat man driving was almost more
fun the combat is very Arkham asked in a
great way amok I agree
exactly exactly Clooney's Batman sucks
it's so funny Clooney hearing him talk
about Batman is really funny look at
this game guys isn't this awesome how
great is this also I hear that I hear
that this spider-man is much more of a
like scientist spider-man rather than
like the photojournalist oh no I'm going
the wrong way how great is this bet it's
so fine oh yeah I love it oh god oh no
oh no but then I screwed it up sorry oh
no no there's an old Incredible Hulk
game that has the record for me of most
fun way to get around the city and this
might take the cake
whoo-hoo we're gonna go this way
Oh No Oh No it's so embarrassing when
you screw up the wet the thing also
somebody was telling me that they had to
get permits for all these buildings and
it's actually oh that's really fun uh
and it's actually super realistic
I love you guys makes me miss New York
by the way New York is never this clean
everyone so they've they've done a great
job cleaning up New York I think we
gotta go this way I have to keep
pressing the button what's up there
let's just run up this building doo doo
doo doo doo doo doo such a fun game
there is actual momentum yes
and there is kind of a rhythm to it that
I'm clearly not getting correctly and
I'm sure I'll be way better after I've
played it for more than 10 minutes but
yes there's absolutely momentum the
physics are great and like the combats
super fun and smooth again I've only
played this game for about 10 minutes
but oh now I'm going the wrong way and
what happens if I don't let go
oh let's go eventually whoa also like
the music like kind of swells as you get
low to the ground which I don't know how
they did that or if it's just me being
crazy but
there we go maybe smaller maybe smaller
swings oh there we go bleh remember the
first spiderman game they had for the
ps1 where you just shot your web out
into the sky yes I do
Tokyo is squeaky clean that's true
rising seven when we were there and you
know we got kind of a little bit of the
typhoon winds and the winds were so
strong they were kind of all pushing us
back like physically pushing me back
you know I weigh like 188 and it was
just like and no trash zero trash flying
around it was incredible
like it was so clean like I was like if
this is New York could be like like you
know rappers and garbage and front you
know Belgian free containers I can old
art - and push forward Oh Thank You Dean
cosmic there we go
how recognizable is this version of New
York for those who live there says read
by Nature I don't know New Yorkers sound
off I lived in New York for nine years
and it I haven't really it feels pretty
oh yeah oh boom I got you bro I got I
got you oh nice whoa baby
love this yeah I don't know a volley
motion how detailed they all are but -
to the side you know what I don't need
are these tutorials let's just take
these off I don't think right we don't
need these tutorials we don't need these
tutorials we don't need these tutorials
guys I guess the tutorials we just have
to have the tutorials on is that right
all right we gotta have the tutorials
that's like how how we want New York to
be yeah I'm guessing - you can probably
upgrade your suit like in Batman to get
a million more cool boom right in the
face
Oh Avengers Tower what kind of embassy
Daredevils law firm that's great oh snap
you really need the tutorials I do Jeff
I guess you're right idea
I'm getting the hang of this swinging
thing it is always a little awkward when
he like has to do it from the side you
know cuz that's not really you wouldn't
really be able to swing Oh God that well
you know like from this like when you're
shooting buildings from the side it's a
little thing Fisk
they used by the way the risk fought for
that for how long do we stream Kim CH 87
we're gonna stream until about 1:00
today and gets to powers and install
mods an upgrade gadgets hell yeah this
game is awesome Ellie I think Conan's up
in his office he by the way quick
Conan office update he's now has another
office on the third floor a mini office
and he's filled with furniture and for
some reason is demanding all his
meetings in there it's just a bit so now
whenever you have a meeting with Conan
you have to go up to a smaller office
and sit but like next to everyone else
which is hilarious so for people
wondering what it's like to work for
Conan it's also great because he's got
bits man he's got bits he's not just a
funny guy in TV yeah that's really the
big day yeah no one was up there no
there was no authority in the third
floor so I know yeah now people are
actually having to spend the entire day
at work
that is the best ah makes me laugh yes
poop man he's built like a spider
zoinks also quick update on my
catchphrases I've started singing songs
for literally no reason and I have no
idea why who says oinks but I'm not
watching River Daryl or anything doesn't
even say in Riverdale oh yeah Scooby Doo
I haven't seen scooby Doo and probably
10 years yet I'm just going to the likes
thanks shaggy boom swing says shaggy
right who's the best spider-man actor I
don't know Jackson Andrew Garfield lives
in my neighborhood I see him all the
time at my coffee shop exactly what's up
drew drew guard I call him drew gar not
a good not a good day for Andrew
Garfield hey drew gar sounds like a
weird Star Trek alien you know Toby was
great I don't really know you know I
think Tom Holland is awesome honestly I
watched a fitting you were four times in
the plane he's really funny I mean I I
don't know like I wouldn't you know it's
quite like in the comic book Miles
Morales is the current spider-man I
would have liked to seen that but in the
new movies but I don't know I thought
Toby was fine okay I was never like a
gigantic spider-man fan I always like
loved his villains more than him himself
let's go zoinks boom it's Britney [ __ ]
that's right I'm bringing the bit knee
to the Britney bit back
just beating the crap out of this one
guy boom all right where we going oh
great oh yeah now we're talking the
beginning of these games are always a
little annoying because you want to do
awesome [ __ ] right away and you kind of
can but not like later in the game and
Batman it's so fun like just jumping
into like 50 enemies is like the best
ooh you know it's always kind of
confused me it's like how does
spider-man get out though those webs are
so sticky how does he get the webbing
off of stuff eating his own webs oh
let's go an event then scan for enemies
bro let's get up in this vein hmm
carnage fest spider-man villainy carnage
is pretty great and insane I think his
cartons gonna be in the new venom movie
nice um by the way how does a new venom
movie look what do we think I love Tom
Hardy by the way it just it I'm gonna
say doesn't look amazing but I'm looking
forward to it if anyone could pull it
off Hardy can unhinge Jordan should be
carnage that's true unhinged Jordan is
the best spider-man villain
okay go am i going here
no nice oh here we go going the wrong
way perfect I've always said it and I'll
always stand by it I love a game or just
tells you where to go just just put the
dot there I don't care if it's realistic
or not just tell me where to go
I really like the trailers so far at sea
where I like the trailers too but it's
like it doesn't connect to the rest of
the Marvel Universe
what are we thinking about like I mean I
kind of like it's one of those trailers
that kind of shows you the whole thing
like he's probably the only guy to
survive this experiment and then let me
heal real quick you know and then like
the bad guy you know takes the serum and
then gets two and then they fight at the
end with the same powers is it kind of
looks like the same thing I do like the
way venom looks is great guru grande we
are here this week we're getting ready
for future projects so we're all here
this week
invisible also the win that's right next
week we have Elizabeth Olsen we got a
lot of big people coming in very
exciting of course some of our other
guests do we even know oh so I shouldn't
have said that
yeah sorry sorry everybody but Marvel
hammers that's right there we go air
launch boom and then you do a yanking
him down howdy fellas
oh wow
you got a little air combat there you
know what I'd like to see like a
spider-man who doesn't have great dance
moves you know wow wow that really hurt
a lot
Jesus God what about like a clumsy
spider-man cuz he's just so graceful
how does he just know how to do this
stuff that's what always my question
Fisk's whole thing is he's like a big
fat guy but he's actually all muscles so
strong
oh man he gets up after that legs are
tough having the venom movies separate
the MCU is good for a solid character
arc right yes that's true but I don't
know man I just worry like because it's
not part of the MCU did they spend
enough time on it did they spend enough
care cuz you know it's in the MCU
they're not gonna have that stuff up oh
boy we got some riot police
well it's disabilities of spider-man
yeah that's true but our spiders really
that graceful I don't know I've managed
to catch a lot of spiders in my day
they're not like wow you know like
spiders aren't like doing this like 24/7
really and was he graceful okay well I
take it back then I have like a like
workmen's like white oh my god Jesus I
guess it was good that Peter Parker got
bit by a graceful kind of spider versus
like a tarantula cuz otherwise he'd just
be like super slow yeah he'd just be
like crack spider is always moving
spiders spend a lot of time on their
nets more like knitting grandmas yeah
you're right you know what it's wait a
spider is way more like a grandma
crocheting something that is like a
crime fighter
I think eyes are just joining us we won
we won an Emmy there it is right there
pretty great it's very sharp
we're playing spider-man today we got a
PlayStation send us an amazing
spider-man box so thank you to
PlayStation for that it's spider-man a
super fun if you don't have this game
definitely worth the 60 bucks
did I disable the QuickTime events in
the settings no I did not why are there
QuickTime events I'm supposed to be
disabling is that good or bad
do we want the things to be disabled I
don't know what that mean I don't I
didn't disable anything any boys yeah
everyone was super nice Conan you know
is amazing and gracious obviously yeah
everyone was incredibly excited
tersh Oh as well they should be oh boy
oh boy how all these you know how
expensive rocket launchers are I mean
come on man I couldn't get them to shoot
rockets at each other I guess Jesus
do that weird oh yeah punch him up and
then smash him down well except he just
got punched up into nowhere turn the
brightness up a bit let it go
here we go come on Fisk where you at
let's go Fisk a little oooh
mid air combat y'all none of you guys
remember that game Devil May Cry but
that had some really fun shoot him up in
the air and then kick him 20 times
combat whoo baby a neat detail I was
done is that there's one set of dialogue
with Spidey is still in another that
sounds more labored when he's fighting
oh that's so cool oh man I think I
kicked that guy's head into the wall I
do you're not killing people you're like
webbing them up or like stunning them
you can't tell me this guy isn't dead
though I mean his back is pretty broken
maybe he's just sleeping with his face
oh yeah that's cool all right Fisk where
you at this just means fish in my
language so you laugh every time uh-oh
these guys aren't as they seem
dude don't don't you guys know his
spider sense God idiot why you gotta try
to fool my boy spider-man yeah that is
cool oh I just got shot a lot
oh Jesus God getting railed over here
let's get these guys on the guns out of
the way first
all of the guys can't have shields and
guns oh I guess they do they
boom another suggest you throw off
buildings do get magically web to a wall
that's funny all right which one's his
office this one there's a lot of open
space in here who just be super annoying
working for this place having to like
walk across this like ten minute hallway
every day it's kind of close skipper
maybe maybe not
guys like bored not saying Bureau would
help but it wouldn't hurt you're never
well honestly I'm not a beard guy more
of a liquor guy you know what they say
beer before liquor never been sicker
liquor before beer gonna you're gonna
have a good night it's gonna be great
champagne for my real friends champagne
for my sham friends champagne for
everybody cuz champagnes delicious
that's what I say Aaron which is yet a
openoffice that's true Jojo yes this is
a funny game why despite ever not use
rubber bullets or melee weapons I don't
know man that's cause it's like
spidering is like his bit he just
spiders around
oh yeah you've got like a spider grenade
or asprin a bayou it's pretty yeah
basically what it's called oh no turrets
this is a good thing it's just like we
have in our office
this operation yeah oh boy
ouch oh you can only web up one at a
time that's fun alright I'll just I'll
just get behind this one then I guess
some web ok good this is going really
well the webbing is going great guys
case anyone was curious the webbing up
is going really good really happy about
it cool great this is going perfect this
is exactly what I want and then oh I
webbed your ass up bro
boom alright web this dude up thank god
he bought the really slow turrets
instead of getting the really good ones
whoa zoinks there's no way zoinks can be
cool or make you feel better about your
zone conan says the turns in front of
his office to deter Jordan that's true
and then Sona has turrets to deter Conan
turn oh sorry
yeah everyone is deterred and I'm a turd
so there you go ooh that hurts quite a
bit ouch ouch ouch
aren't you fast for your size you can
only really hit him like four times by
the way you got to kind of back off but
they want you to he liked the the game
wants you to hit him more it wants you
know what you to keep hitting him Oh
miss me yep you're a big crazy bald guy
just chill out what's your power oh oh
god oh oh attempts that punch was very
telegraphed he was like go I have like
no health so I think I'm probably gonna
die here let's see what happens I guess
playing a 24 hour stream anytime soon a
sock I'm not sure we're not blue moon
wolf tell me about your personal life
while I'm back on the apps and the
darkness closes in quickly yeah so there
you go
whoa miss me baby
what's that oh man this game is fun Wow
now you're getting hit in the face
though ow
do
Jesus Christ I just got hit by like 16
people well hey hey you can heal while
dodging that's fun
ouch yeah clearly how's that handling
yourself going Oh God
I do like the fact that he can hit his
own guys I think that's cool
I don't know man
oh boy just need one more web
I do like the thing where you can your
web thing pulls you close in is real
that's a fun mechanic for sure oh here
we go
oh no kiss him kiss each other every
time there's a big thing I own Oh what's
gonna happen boom oh damn oh my god I
love this like cutscene battles are
awesome oh snap
zoinks get it get him get him oh my god
this building so big this is building
and why is every floor smashable it
doesn't seem very safe there's like 9
skylights we just fell through it's
ridiculous
spider II could stop a crane for falling
on to NYC but can't get punched by a
henchman once before dying that's true
it seems a little uh kingpin is
full-grown Gerber baby mafia boss oh hey
go to the hey hey can you go to the this
guy needs like a moisturizing face mask
or something
oh my god
Pete easel gaming am i on meth well I'm
coming down from it
that's still on it yeah dude it says
Emmy hi when you're this close to gold
baby whoo you know exactly this thing by
the way I will say it's like
legitimately heavy it's like she says
it's like it's more than 5 pounds it's
probably eight pounds that's it's heavy
man it's great uh whoo level up level
one look at this beautiful city guys
this is amazing let's go to the skill
tree yeah let's not worry about the top
let's get out of the skill tree okay
don't make me do a skill tree thing it's
do a little slinging how do I get off
this pole am I just trapped on this pole
forever
there we go oh wow it's definitely gonna
take some getting used to like zipping
all over the city all right chill out
bro don't harsh my mellow I just kicked
the crap out of Wilson Fisk
aren't we passive-aggressive oh hey look
at this MSG oh this is so cool
those birds l-3 in the air oh my god
whoa this is great
I love getting really close to their
ground
do-do-do-do-do-do-do this also feels a
bit like the Assassin's Creed games in
terms of the fun parkour stuff
this is great the trees look great this
game is awesome man
oh this is look at the reflection in the
building Fred sent me a picture the
Ghostbusters firestation
oh that's cool I think I got to go over
here or something hi everyone hello hey
chill out all right don't make me angry
can I pick up a car anything why is
everyone afraid of spider-man the fist
guy can't break thin handcuffs yeah
seriously all right I guess we gotta go
pee right you know I don't think New
Yorkers would be that mean - spider-man
they'd appreciate him right don't you
think overly like pissed off in this
game I were playing the original ps4 not
the PS Pro although we did get is this a
pro it feels like it yeah it's so penny
it's something
JJ's right spider-man is a menace that
guy used to go to my gym what's-his-face
I think of whiplash the bad guy the bald
guy who might think you have oh my god
Jay no not Jay be smooth I was gonna say
JK rowling yeah JK Simmons go to my gym
guys guys by the way he's ripped yeah he
is ripped JK Simmons is rich and super
nice really nice to you not yeah not
quite my tempo would I be afraid of a
guy in a skin-tight sooo the mascot
flying around town no I would not
it's doc ock man daka's our boss that's
an interesting thing there's a high
button you could point finger guns
that's so cool never forget he refused
to sell out spider-man to Green Goblin
Oh miracle Knight
oh really doc ock that's pretty cool oh
no Jay jonah Jameson wouldn't sell out
yeah that's true you're right I don't
know why they put plots in the
spider-man games it was just swinging on
the web and nothing else I would play
gladly yeah but like soon Roger doesn't
it make it that much better that there's
a plot this is fun love you - Neha love
you too six or a two there are two chats
yes there's the YouTube chat and the
twitch chat but I'm reading them both
baby don't worry you know what that's
right guys this Emmy is for all of you
it's for uh for for all all fans
everywhere who watch us to support us
doing so it's very heavy I wish I could
hold it and play but I can't
that's right guys wanna listen to this
listen to this that's what the Emmy
sounds like that's right you want to
smell it
put your put your face up to this that's
gold
yeah that's crazy I mean it's heavy and
it's worth a I would imagine quite a bit
of money all right
of course I have to do something gross
with it sorry I'm sorry Beth don't look
away Beth look away from the screen I'm
very excited for cyberpunk 2077 also
also very sad for death stranding let's
see here do you think doc ock would just
leave his iPad out unlocked come on dude
cyberpunk 2077 looks awesome i watch the
entire gameplay it looks great
oh I have to oh okay this is fun this is
um what's happening here
Oh rotate
I can't rotate it WTF man it's all
locked this is great
oh I see I have to put more things down
this is really fun in what was this this
was Bioshock Bioshock had a really cool
mechanic whereby yeah you did this and
so yeah it's kind of fun like I remember
doing games like this as a kid so it's
awesome that I'm glad it's paying off
later in life Epona repaired great this
is gonna be really fun for the chat
watching munis sorry in advance
everybody
oh no this game reminds you that Peter
Parker is a scientist and not a hero by
trade yes that's true
exactly I like that and I also like like
you know it's really fun that either
they lean into this kind of stuff I love
that because it makes it it does make
the character you know Oh interesting
okay more multi-dimensional which is
great
let's see now they're switching up on us
a little bit guys switching up on us
because in a weird way like I think that
in a certain way
interesting wait so I have to do this
it's not gonna work
oh man that's like a real hard puzzle
but yeah yeah certainly I think like a
lot of comic movie creators get really
hung up on being true to the comic books
only in plot like oh we have to do this
so the origin story has to match and all
that stuff but in reality it's stuff
like making Peter Parker a scientist
making a Batman a detective these things
kind of are small things that in a
certain way at me is a comic book fan
ring more true right guys I would say
now Beth I'm gonna need your help here
because I think we're out of tourney
pieces we need another one of these
pieces that are a zero but we can't do
that I don't know how we do I don't know
how we solve this let's start over let's
start over let's start over okay we got
to get over here right we can't go in
here so we have to do this right and
then we got to do a straight one right I
can't can I go down maybe I bet I bet
you I can't go down we only have one
other Turney piece oh yes yeah I can't
go down there this is gonna guide this
is gonna be the rest of the stream I'm
really sorry right oh wait oh I think
that oh this goes either way oh I'm
stupid that don't look go pretend
pretend I never asked you for help
because got it yeah no way this one no
we want to do this one here sorry
everybody I know this sucks this sucks I
know everyone well he's much smarter
than I am
obviously he's incredibly smart
meanwhile the rest of the stream is me
just turning octagon pieces
like an idiot all right sorry Jojo HIV
yes the chat is filled with help I
really appreciate it guys
it's I'm dumb I like Michigan State it's
a great farm school I'm not disparaging
state I just didn't get a good education
because I didn't apply myself okay now
what what's happening let's go all right
red one easy green one easy right
am I missing something here I am missing
something right oh you can really no
well I just pressed r1 and it's not
working there we go
all right guys we did it this will be
just five more hours by the way where
are all the people that are in charge of
coding the website or anything yeah yes
yes exactly there wait didn't we do this
actual voltage target oh we got to get a
better voltage right or something it's
taking one two oh my god Jesus Christ oh
wait I know let's just take this one out
and then we'll put where's my other
inventory can I go back the other way
I guess not oh you hear I guess we
should do this or something oh my god
it's the worst I bet you I can bet you I
can't use the green one here yep only a
red one that's his too this is 104 just
let's skip this yeah
let's skip this content all right we're
skip again we're skipping it skipping
this content success wow this game is
really yeah we did it kids just you know
that's right stay in school and remember
if something's too hard don't do it if
at first you don't succeed in English
then just stop and major in English yeah
let's see if it works
oh my god this is guys here we go good
as new I could still make gross gestures
oh hey I can do go all the way up
exactly
all right we did it well we just helped
rocks become a building for the
prosthetics well we don't have time
let's get out of here
we don't don't now I got to review this
work uh whoever said the thing about the
plots and games I feel I feel like now
I'm regretting the fact I said plots are
great but no to be fair though this is
only on a stream in real life I love
this playing plots and this stuff and
honestly like it's amazing stories that
elevate a video game to higher levels
you know what I'm saying what would god
of war be without the story well the
last of us be without the story what
would this be without the story nothing
and just be a bunch of swinging around
and nobody wants that alright so I'm
very into this unknown substance tent
and it's like they're in my bathroom I'm
so disgusting oh no oh god guys we could
no we could do this this is just a child
could dude it's just pattern recognition
right guys we did it there we go
we're doing basically 23andme it's what
we're doing Samson's identified crunchy
Cheetos it gets more fun later in this
story I agree yes you got it you got to
weave the tapestry here we go
what would pong be what would the story
behind pong be how about two twins
fighting over who has to go yeah exactly
holy Moses oh cool all right all right
so this is kind of like an extra thing
we can do that we're not doing now great
we don't need to do this
oh okay this is great extra stuff loving
the extra stuff guys very cool yep okay
let's quit out of here cuz I'm dumb all
right it's just showing us some extra
fun things we can do for XP which I will
be doing later
but now let's get back out there there's
a lot of webs to be swung you know and
we've only got 8 more minutes for
children aged Conan and up I want to
play spider-man already why do we sell
exclusive 2018 I don't know but I get
the get the PlayStation it's worth it
put the square block in the square hole
well me and Conan be playing Red Dead
Redemption - I sure hope so
cuz I love that game but I've a feeling
to be playing this for quite a bit of
time the raft love the raft the raft is
we're thinking the Avengers that's where
they send cap and those guys over there
oh my god wait does it get dark it feels
like it's like nighttime it's like
Golden Hour
oh man guys who have played this game if
there are a night time in this game
because that is their night time in this
game yeah oh my god really
I gotta say oh my god that's awesome
holy crap that's so cool
by the way spider-man team every time I
fly through a tree it's the best day of
my life
whoo baby oh my god really that's
awesome I gotta say like it's not all
that's I love going close to the thing
it's not that hard once you kind of get
used to the rhythm it's super fun here
we go
in several markets harder cuz you guys
swing from trees a shot of the to murder
there we go
I know Cassius I wish like they just
played like Empire State of Mind by
jay-z after the game you could change
time of day and free roam oh that's fun
it gets rainy with fog yes
oh yeah Carl Lander you finish the game
you can change the time that's awesome I
don't remember Yuri from the comics dude
how are you press the daylight cycle goo
Mach I'm not impressed with the daylight
cycle and I loved ocarina time either
one of my favorite games I'm just
impressed at how beautiful this game
looks I can't wait to see what the night
time looks like I'm impressed that it's
great I'm glad they did that it makes me
happy Easter dish thank you
make sure Conan doesn't see that or I'll
be fired immediately press X at the end
of its swing to jump and go faster
alright I'm in the original movies
weren't great that's true
one thing I love look at this that's a
leave this tower who matched the
wavelength okay I'm done skis oh so we
unlocked it do you like the towers that
soon you like the maps very cool I know
I love Beth as the expert on spider-man
this is my favorite can you shot my dad
out John okay chill okay is John you
were your dad either way oh snap
let's go stop a crime oh this is kind of
obvious dudes if you're gonna first of
all first rule of committing a crime on
the street don't wear ski masks ski mask
just says we're committing a crime I do
like that guys tracksuit Oh baby oh this
is great hey fellas enemies with melee
weapons a blockbuster tax revolver to
air launch attacks webs and throw balls
got it
I also like that this is like it's not a
button masher but you're gonna press
with you buttons to do like a lot of
very impressive thing yeah it is really
oh dang oh they do block a lot of stuff
that's interesting whoo look at this
that's fun
Daily Bugle for the win while I work
with Conan since oh one a long time some
would say too long
mostly Conan would say that is great
oh this is great
why are all these guys wearing
tracksuits come on man look at a camo
brown camo jacket doesn't go with a
green shirt
these guys are committing crimes against
fashion everybody oh yeah here we go
pow pow whoo brute supply banks I webbed
you up bro ooh
we got a bit of a brood over here okay I
don't mean uh Webster web him up oh geez
all right I get you
oh man oh my god I'm getting mail this
guy jeez Oh Pete oh I'm gonna get killed
by a brute no oh well you know what I
hate to say it guys but perfect timing
it's 1:00 p.m. which means our stream is
at an end thank you all for joining us
for stream Coco ah spider-man was
amazing I'm gonna pause it
ah this game was great thank you so much
for to PlayStation again for sending us
this crazy box good lord this is amazing
thank you once again go out and get this
game it's on real and not just because
we got the incredible insane thing thank
you to our friends at PlayStation and of
course again thank you to you guys the
fans for winning us is awesome Emmy
thank you so much make sure to watch our
color Without Borders specials if you
haven't already they're great and fun
and catch up on everything we did in
Japan last week team koco.com / japan
there's nothing there yet so don't go
there but on our Facebook page there's a
bunch of live stuff on our Instagram
Instagram flash Team Coco make sure
you're following that and of course at
Conan O'Brien on Twitter thank you all
for joining us we will see you guys next
week make sure to watch our shows coming
back on Monday
have a great day see you later
[Music]